[Music]
hey you guys tomes of terror time once
again this is my book review series
so this particular book this is how
this [ __ ] usually goes i mean unless
somebody recommends something i usually
pick a lot of stuff at random uh and
that was absolutely the case with this
one
um i had really only heard of this
author sarah graham like kind of
peripheral peripherally i guess she was
mentioned in a couple of other uh book
review channels i watch i think uh so
when i came across her novella
come closer i actually wasn't aware of
uh there were two things that i weren't
aware of one that it was actually as old
as it was it's not old old but you know
it's
it's about 20 years old um and two how
recently i guess it had something of
like a resurgence in popularity i guess
following the success of grande's later
series of books which have a character
named claire dewitt i think she started
writing those in 2011 if i'm not
mistaken and i think like the last one
maybe came out in 2018 and those are
like really popular so i guess some
people are like rediscovering some of
her older novels
so
pretty much i was just kind of like
you know with a lot of my book review
pics i just saw come closer pop up in my
kindle unlimited recommendations i
thought i remembered the author's name
from somewhere uh the cover looked cool
i didn't read the synopsis or anything
like that but i just like was like
checked it out and started reading it
so this novella as i mentioned came out
back in 2003.
now as i was reading it i didn't know
that like prior to reading it as i
mentioned um so it didn't actually
really occur to me other than there
being one reference in there like to a
character you know maybe you should get
one of those newfangled cell phone types
that's not what they said but it was
like that kind of thing and other than
that i really can't think of anything
that would have dated it all that much
which like i said is actually really
good because you know the book is almost
20 years old and that absolutely would
not have probably occurred to me it just
seems like it hasn't dated at all so uh
the book is also very short and sweet
clocks in at just under 200 pages i
think it's about 194 or something like
that
and i was able to finish it off very
easily in one afternoon and this was one
of those books too where because you
know how sometimes like sometimes you
start reading a book and it takes you a
little while to like warm up to it like
a few pages this one i was just kind of
like drawn in right away i'm not sure
entirely what it was i think it was
probably like her writing style which
kind of comes into it's very
straightforward it's very acerbic like
it's kind of like has a blackly comic
kind of tone to it and it's almost kind
of like conversational
so i tend to usually like that kind of
style or at least it gets me invested
quicker uh so i will say that yeah this
drew me like right in and i was just
like kept on reading it and it just like
i basically just read it in a couple of
hours like in one sitting and i will say
too that this book really packs kind of
like a hell of a wallop for being you
know for the scant page count that it
has
and as it goes on it sort of becomes
something akin to maybe like watching
a horrifying plane crash that you know
is inevitable but you're kind of like
powerless to stop it you know what i
mean so it's that kind of like story so
come closer is told from the first
person perspective of a 34 year old
woman named amanda
now she lives in this kind of unnamed
but large metropolitan city somewhere
presumably in the u.s it doesn't really
matter
she works as a successful architect at
sort of a smaller firm but she's kind of
well on track to setting up her own firm
in the near future so like i said very
successful
she also has a dependable
very loving husband whose name is ed or
edward he works as a financial
consultant or something like that um and
she lives in this beautiful loft
apartment in a kind of desolate uh you
know not as populated area but it's kind
of like a peaceful corner of the city
so to that end the couple seem kind of
like your typical upper middle class
urbanites they don't have any kids
bogging them down uh you know they go to
fancy work dinners they have friends
that have a beach house you know they
have expensive shoes and purses and [ __ ]
like that you know what i mean
uh well i don't know because i've never
lived like that but you know you've
probably seen it in the movies so it's
the kind of life uh one would think that
many people would absolutely kill for
and that you know people should be happy
with however at the very beginning of
the story something seems ever so
slightly off
the first occurrence which happens like
pretty much on the very first page
has to do with this proposal at work
that amanda has written and submitted to
her boss
i mean she spent all weekend working on
it she thinks it's impeccable and she
certs sure it's going to be approved and
it's going to be like some big project
that she's going to you know get a
promotion or whatever
but then she gets called into the boss's
office and basically he just like reams
her a new one because the proposal she
thought she printed on turned in has
been
seemingly replaced with this sort of
slur-filled rant calling the boss all
kinds of names and implying some very
colorful things about his sexual
proclivities
so amanda is actually shocked by this uh
happenstance and she insists somebody
has to be playing a prank on me like
somebody printed this out on my computer
like somebody's playing a joke uh so
then she goes back to her computer and
prints out a copy of the actual uh
proposal which would she thought she
turned in and then she turns that in so
the boss is actually mollified she's
worked there a long time and they know
that it's not usually the kind of thing
that she would do so she's like okay
well you know the boss is like yeah
you're right uh somebody just must be
playing a joke on you that's really
really weird now even though amanda is
convinced that that must have been what
happened that somebody somehow came in
and like printed out the wrong thing
privately she's a little bit weirded out
because all of the terrible things that
were said in the proposal she's like i
have actually thought those things about
my boss so it's really weird that
somebody actually like wrote them down
and then there's the other like small
matter of these very strange tapping
sounds that her and her husband ed have
been hearing back at their loft where
they live
now the sounds always come in pairs it's
kind of like tap tap tap tap and she
said it sounds something like a dog's
nails like clicking on a wooden floor or
something like that
uh and they sometimes go on for hours
but significantly they only occur when
amanda is in the apartment but never
when ed is there alone and like one time
when she goes off on a business trip he
says yeah it didn't do it the whole
entire time you were gone
now whenever her or ed go looking for
the source of the noise they can never
quite pinpoint it it sounds if it sounds
like it's coming from the living room
for example and then they go check in
the living room then it'll sound like
it's coming from the kitchen you know
and so forth there's also this stray dog
that amanda befriends near the beginning
of the story kind of on her daily walk
home like from the train station like
she's coming home from work and she's
walking over the train station is like a
stray dog and she sees the dog every day
so the dog is a german shepherd and
initially he's very affectionate toward
her and so she kind of like gets used to
him walking home with her so she starts
bringing treats and stuff like that
she thinks about adopting him but i
guess ed is allergic to animals so she
can't
but as time goes on the dog seems like
it no longer recognizes her and starts
like growling when she approaches uh by
the way nothing bad happens to the dog
so don't worry um you know i'm an animal
lover too and every time a dog or a cat
like appears in a horror story my little
my stomach always clenches i'm like oh
no this poor little baby this poor
little baby something bad's gonna happen
but nothing bad happens to the dog okay
so i'm just telling you right there i
understand that's you know so i just
thought i had to tell you tell you that
and there are also a bunch of other
little things like she takes up smoking
again uh in spite of her husband's
protest oh my god you quit such a long
time ago and it's bad for your health
blah blah
she starts shoplifting and not really
realizing that she did so um you know
she has kind of little brief like
blackouts where she's like oh you know
like one time she's at work and she goes
out to lunch and then she has like an
hour that she can't account for which
she doesn't know what she was doing
um she gets more easily irritated with
her husband like picking petty fights
with him and also starts snapping at
strangers for just like minor slights
she gets the feeling uh overall that her
personality
is changing like in small and subtle
ways
and when she happens upon friends that
haven't seen her in a long time
they always tell her she looks different
like maybe
you're you've gained a little weight but
you look good like you look healthy you
look happy but they can't ever put their
finger quite on what it is that's
different about her like maybe your skin
looks nicer maybe you're pregnant maybe
you know what i mean it's always kind of
like did you get your hair done or did
you get some work done or something like
that they always say like she looks
better but they can't like put her put
their finger on what it is that's
different and then there are also these
weird dreams that she's been having so
she's gonna have these really odd like
recurring dreams about
it's like a beach or like an island like
a beach with crimson sand and there's
also like crimson water
and then there's this kind of beautiful
but sort of sinister looking dark-haired
woman who lies next to her on the sand
and tells her how much she loves her and
i'm never gonna leave you and all this
other kind of stuff so this woman
actually bears an uncanny resemblance to
uh how amanda pictured her childhood
imaginary friend whose name was pansy
and on one occasion
amanda even swears that she sees pansy
in the street and she goes up to where
the woman like calls her by name
but then like when she turns back like
she's not there anymore so of course ed
doesn't believe her when she tells him
later but she's like absolutely sure
that she saw her now one day by chance
or so it seems amanda receives the wrong
book in the mail she had ordered this
architecture book from a small press
but they accidentally sent one about
demon possession
for a lark
you know just thinking why the hell not
amanda takes the demon possession quiz
which is featured in the first part of
the book
and is amused but also mildly disturbed
by the fact that she scores like a 3 or
4 out of 10 on the quiz
now the possession quiz actually becomes
sort of like a recurring plot point
throughout the story like amanda takes
it a few more times like as the story
goes on and like as things start to
escalate and she scores higher and
higher each time she takes it so
essentially come closer is a demon
possession story but told from the first
person perspective of the possessee
which is not something i think that i've
ever actually read before if there's
another one like that like let me know
but i don't i can't remember ever
reading anything like from exactly that
perspective uh it's very grounded in
reality like it's maybe supernatural but
it doesn't really have anything it comes
at it from a very grounded uh point of
view and it has sort of like a kind of
like a black humor to it i feel like
this is pretty much exactly what it
would be like if demons were real
and one was slowly taking over your body
but you weren't quite aware that that's
exactly what was happening to you you
know what i mean so that's kind of like
the tone we're going for
now in fact the story does leave the
possibility open that amanda is just
descending into madness and maybe just
perceiving it as possession
but because you the reader are seeing
everything from amanda's pov there's
really no way of knowing that for sure i
mean this could absolutely be read
either
absolutely literally or metaphorically
you know and it works just the same
either way now i think the thing that i
liked the most about this book i mean
other than just about everything because
i really really liked this a lot was how
cleverly insidious it was
like you as the reader are
in many ways in the same position as the
protagonist amanda like at the beginning
of the story she seems content enough
but
pretty much everybody can relate to
maybe sometimes feeling dissatisfied
with your life like maybe we want
something different than what we have or
things didn't turn out quite the way we
wanted them to like we don't have as
much control over what happened
something like that i feel like most
people have probably had fantasies about
blowing up their stable but boring lives
and going off and doing something crazy
like changing their entire life up it's
a very natural human inclination and i
feel like this story like very
effectively like uses it against you i
mean so when amanda like takes up
smoking again it doesn't seem as though
she's possessed necessarily it's more
like she's
reclaiming some of her own personality
that perhaps she's suppressed for the
sake of her husband when she married you
know health concerns be damned
when she for example like claps back at
someone in the street for being an
[ __ ] we see it not so much as like a
demon worming its way into her psyche
maybe but maybe more like oh amanda is
learning to be more assertive like she's
learning to like not let people push her
around something like that which is a
good thing so in this way i kind of feel
like the reader starts to identify with
amanda uh somewhat like to a greater or
lesser degree
nothing that happens at first is all
that bad and the thing about it and like
i said you can relate to a way it's like
you know who wouldn't want to like tell
their boss what they really think of
them to their face who wouldn't you know
kind of want to put let their hair down
sometimes and oh i'll just have that
extra shot of whiskey i'll buy that
super expensive outfit that i can't
really afford but it's so cool and i
really want it i mean who wouldn't like
to do that kind of stuff it's all
perfectly understandable but the hell of
this story is that it's these very
incremental desires mostly harmless in
their early stages obviously that kind
of slowly ramp up and up until
amanda has been entirely consumed by
this demon and whether it's real or not
it does absolutely
cause her to just completely burn down
her entire life to a point where she is
resorting to violence and even kind of
like murder like toward the end so
it's still like i said it whether the
demon is real or not like doesn't really
matter and you can totally read it
either way so as i mentioned i really
really liked this i liked this book a
lot this was just outstanding it's very
very uh fast paced it's very compelling
very page turning it's darkly funny
which i really liked like the humor in
it and it's also like kind of terrible
like the implications of it are kind of
terrifying it doesn't have any twists
and turns really um it's basically just
a very simple tale of a woman who is
either possessed by a demon or
succumbing to insanity and ultimately
ends up destroying herself and those
around her so there aren't any surprises
really as far as the plot goes but it's
still like a really wild and very grimly
entertaining ride even though you know
like i said it's almost kind of like
watching like a slow motion car crash
like you know that it's gonna happen but
it's just kind of like you can't do
anything to stop it and you're just like
sit there sitting there like powerless
and you're just like watching it like in
horrified fascination it's kind of like
that um so i absolutely wouldn't
hesitate to recommend this to anyone
who's into psychological horror
possession horror
it does have something of a literary
fiction bent if you want to call it that
but
not so much in the writing style like i
said it's very uh matter of fact it's
very conversational because it's in the
first person so you're pretty much
inside amanda's head pretty much the
entire time so it's not real highfalutin
or anything like that it's just very
visceral it's very straightforward and i
think that really really works a lot to
its advantage and makes it
that much more entertaining and more
horrifying because you're seeing
everything from her perspective and
you're not entirely sure like you can
see how her life is spiraling out of
control and you can't really do anything
to stop her to help it and i think that
helper and i think that's like really
really uh scary and it's really really
entertaining at the same time so that
will do it for this uh tomes of terror
as i mentioned this book is available on
kindle unlimited uh so if you have
kindle unlimited you can read it for
free it's very short less than 200 pages
so you should probably like be able to
finish it off in an afternoon because
it's a really really fun read as well so
uh yeah that'll do it for this one i
will see you guys on the next one bye